[Music]
yes
is
foreign
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
yes
[Music]
no worse
[Music]
somebody else said
it is 12.45
customers
[Music]
uh
yes
oh
is
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
um
i am truly grateful for the warm
hospitality that you showed me in kabul
a few months ago and i'm very glad to
greet you here in washington
so thanks to you and your entire
delegation sarah for making the trip
let me also thank you you're your
excellency for
your leadership and all your efforts
during this historic time
i like to stress again right now from
the outset that
the department of defense is deeply
invested
in the security and stability of
afghanistan
and in the pursuit of a negotiated
settlement that ends
the war let me reaffirm
america's commitment to an enduring
partnership
with afghanistan especially our strong
defense relationship
i also want to acknowledge the shared
sacrifices of both the u.s and afghan
forces
you know back when i was in uniform mr
president
i was in afghanistan and we helped to
stand up the very first battalion
of afghan security forces in battle
after battle
year after year american and afghan
soldiers have fought side by side
in common purpose many of them have paid
the ultimate
price these brave men and women have
made
possible important economic social and
political progress
and we cannot ever thank them for their
families
them and their families enough for what
they have given
now as i made clear back in april when
we announced our decision in brussels
the united states remains committed to
continuing to
provide critical security assistance to
the afghan
national defense and security forces
i am confident that as resolute support
begins to wind down
we will make the transition to a new
relationship with afghanistan and the
afghan forces
one that continues to help you meet your
responsibilities to your citizens
and we will remain partners with the
afghan government
and the afghan military and we will
continue to work toward
our common goal in
new and different ways again sir thank
you
for being here and i look forward to our
discussion today
let me first pay tribute to the 248th
americans
who paid out with sacrifice for your
security in our food
and let me thank over a million
men and women in uniform generals
your distinguished self uh officers
men and women uh who
have served and have once done with
honoring distinction
last night i had a meeting with the
veterans
and with some of the members of the gold
star families my request to you
and to the distinguished men in uniform
is to please convey our deepest thanks
and gratitude uh to these heroes
uh what together we've created
particularly on behalf of the afghan
security forces thank you for
acknowledging
our sacrifice we
have to you had the choice but
your choice was the right one and
the move the words of general kelly
regarding his son
who died in helmand
has been among the most moving
words that i've read so please
convey our deepest thanks and gratitude
you represent
an extraordinary honorable tradition
you've been there
from the foundation store with the first
division uh through the content of this
to the sitcom uh again i had the honor
of
meeting you with you and working with
you and now as
the secretary of defense
uh the decision in labor i think is a
strategic decision that changes the
calculus of everybody
and the need for shifting from war to
peace
i think the implications of this are
profound
and we are here to discuss how to
make that a joint success
i've been speaking to congress my
colleagues and i've been speaking to
congress
and to others
we respect the decision and our joint
goal is that our success
is a joint success because of that
the transition to a new partnership
is defining
this partnership in a manner that serves
as always a mutual interest based on
mutual respect
in mutual trust is crucial and we trust
the second viewers and those of the
president
that afghanistan is entering into a new
phase
of partnership the
false narrative of abandonment is just
false
we have a lot together
and together we will accomplish on our
side
please understand that our determination
as a nation as a public
for you we have our 1861 moment
when president lincoln entered
washington
besieged she misundered
and and on the verge of
an actual war but
his approach of unity
team of rivals finding his
in german uh worked success
ultimately saved the republic that under
the threat
afghanistan is a similar approach
the republic is strong groups in support
but i'm sure together we'll be able to
the difference was that president rincon
didn't have foreign
international support we do and we
counted
in terms of that our issues
are now operational and issues
over a horizon they are not issues or
principles
there are issues of process and i've
explained
the distinguished members of congress
were very gratified
by the support supporters bipartisan
support but we've
assured them that they should not
be over worried the situation of course
presents challenges
but today between the morning when were
discussing
the openness of the northern routes and
now uh
the road for homie has been open where
forces
significant progress has been made the
will and the capacity is there
it's the question of making sure
that in the discussions that we have
with you we get the operational issues
right
may ask dr
to say some words
in support of
um
there was an opportunity to talk on much
broader security
issues with your experience
experience in leadership here
making this transition and materializing
it in a way that our common interest
is preserved and the
enemies of us and enemies of peace and
instability which are terrorists
are not taking advantage of this and
then how to
work together to stabilize the situation
so the
efforts and support of peace also
breakthroughs to the people of
afghanistan
and i also joined the president
remembering the falling in order
honoring their memories
and also expressing our gratitude
for those who have served hundreds of
thousands of people
it has made a big difference in our
partnership
which and very clear response
and answer to that was no first
you have dealt with an enemy which would
have hit us
much harder and if not in that one the
way
it was done in afghanistan which was
also
as a result of common sacrifices and the
second
the changes in the lives of afghanistan
which has occurred
these are permanent today of course
perhaps those who are fighting against
us they think that there is an
opportunity
and they might be able to take
advantage of this but i'm sure with the
resolve of the african people
leadership there and also unity
in the department and also the continued
commitment of our partners
the united states at least partner the
announcement of
the invitation by president to our team
to the president and us all together and
to express that commitment and also the
opportunity to have with all of you
here to talk about the
work ahead of us in the new chapter that
will turn it into
a common sense
thank you dr fellow and uh and thank you
so we'll go ahead and uh in transition
mr president can we ask you about the
intelligence report
thank you
about a week ago
[Music]
all right
[Music]
oh
you look more
sit down
[Music]
yes two questions
there's a new comedy routine here no
it's just a reference to a movie
what was the book you did bob give me
this
you know
uh
[Music]
is
is
is right
yes
all right
um
yes
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
baby
you go
plate
[Music]
okay
you come from both sides
[Music]
oh
thank
yeah
oh yeah
thank you um
i was over here
oh
is
is
i don't think
hello
we have
i also
there's like one building that's
different
i'm sorry
oh
all right
oh
good to see you happy pride celebrating
here today
okay i'm just going to give you a quick
overview of the week ahead
on monday the president will welcome
israeli president
rivlin to the white house president
rivlin's visit will highlight the
enduring partnership between the united
states and israel and the deep ties
between our governments
and our people as president rivlin
approaches the end of his term
the visit will honor the dedication he
has shown to strengthening the
friendship between the two countries
over the course of many years on tuesday
the president will travel to southwest
wisconsin
with secretary of agriculture tom
vilsack to talk about growing
agriculture
growing agriculture and rural economies
on wednesday he will convene cabinet
officials governors
from western states and private sector
partners to discuss the devastating
intersection of drought heat and
wildfires
in the western united states and
strengthening prevention preparedness
and response efforts for this wildfire
season
which is already outpacing last season
all
alone outpiecing last season alone sorry
the 2020 wildfire season alone
burned over 10 million acres across the
united states resulting in the loss of
dozens of lives and tens of billions of
dollars
in economic damage this meeting will
focus on how the federal government
can most effectively protect public
safety and deliver assistance to our
people
in times of urgent need and on friday
the president will also deliver remarks
on the june jobs report
next week even while all of this is
going on a busy week the president will
also continue to
work and engage closely with members of
congress about moving his agenda
forward whether it's the bipartisan
infrastructure agreement just announced
yesterday or
the budget reconciliation process that's
also moving forward
and he will continue to on his work to
protect the sacred right to vote you'll
hear from him
next week on that we're still finalizing
the details and he's been engaged in
that work through his career so you'll
hear more
from him on that next week i'd also note
so i don't forget
today is jerome's last day in the white
house briefing room as a white house
correspondent so
um thank you to your service to the
public over the last
several years all right
why don't we kick it off darlene thank
you jen um is the infrastructure
agreement already stuck in a pothole
[Laughter]
you worked hard on that i like it
uh absolutely not in our view uh the
president
uh is continuing to as i said as he said
yesterday
there's work ahead there's no question
about that but yesterday was a
significant moment when you saw
democrats and republicans and the
president of the united states
stand outside together and say we've
come to agreement to pat
to work for toward passing a historic
investment in infrastructure
one that would have i just have this
handy chart up here i thought someone
might ask about this
um would have key components that would
help communities across the country and
i talked with him about this this
morning what he was most excited about
what he's going to continue what his
message is going to be
as he continues to advocate for this
bill moving forward
one is the significant economic impact
it's going to help create millions of
good-paying union jobs
it will also have a huge impact on
low-income communities on communities of
color
it will eliminate lead pipes to stop
kids from drinking poison water
flint michigan should not be so far away
that we don't remember the impact on
that community
this is a part of this package will help
prevent that from ever happening again
it includes the single largest
investment in environmental remediation
in history what does that mean a lot of
people at home don't know what that
means so i'm going to explain it
and it's 100 of what he asked for it
means cleaning up pollution in
communities that have disproportionately
borne the brunt of environmental
pollution
it's a capping it also means capping
wells for big oil companies
left wells uncapped with methane pouring
out it means putting people back to work
to do the work we need to do
to help create a clean energy economy
for the long
term and has the largest investment in
public transit in our nation's history
we know this will also have an enormous
impact on low-income communities
many communities of color i'll also note
there are huge components of this
package that will help address the
climate crisis
one is the first ever first ever network
first time we've ever invested sorry in
a network of ev charging stations across
the country so electric vehicles
i don't currently own one maybe i will
in the future who knows
it will make it easier there will be
more charging stations so people can use
them across the country
it will have the largest investment in
history and a clean energy transmission
grit something that will also help us
take
a huge step forward and this bill also
will help us and this is a piece he
talked about yesterday but he's
particularly excited about us make us
more competitive in the world and a
specific example there
is making sure we are building our
battery industry here in the united
states to compete globally so
that's the case he's making uh he's
going to continue to make
there's no question there's work ahead
and he's ready to roll up the sleeves
and work like hell to get it done
but we're hearing from the hill from a
lot of senators that uh
unhappiness over the president's
decision to want to do both these
packages at the same time the preparing
moving them in tandem
when senators agreed to this deal was
the white house upfront
with them that this was the way the
president wanted to proceed
first you all have heard the president
say multiple times publicly that he
wanted to
he was going to move these bills forward
wanted to move them forward in parallel
paths
and that's exactly what's happening that
hasn't been a secret he hasn't said it
quietly he hasn't even whispered it he
said it very much
out loud to all of you as we have said
many times from here
i will say that the president's view is
that the public the american people
elected him to not lead on process but
to get
things done uh the house and senate are
going to determine
the leaders in the house and senate are
going to determine the sequencing the
timeline and he looks forward to signing
both pieces of legislation
what is the plan for will we get a
statement from the president after their
uh derek shoven
is sentenced do you expect the president
will
call george boyd's family be in touch
with them after the sentences
it's a great question darlene i i don't
i don't have any anticipate i i don't
have anything to preview for you i guess
i should say at this point we'll wait
for the
sentencing to come out as you know he
has a close personal connection with the
floyd family
and certainly i know they and we are all
watching this closely go ahead
does the president have any plans to
visit surfside to see the devastation
for himself
well i would say first that any decision
along those lines would be done in
coordination and cooperation with local
authorities as you know and you all have
been covering this closely
right now we're in a rescue and recovery
phase of this and there have been
frequent updates from local authorities
on the ground so
i don't have any uh trip to preview or
predict for you at this point in time
how did the vice president choose el
paso as the
location for her first trip to the
border as vice president
uh it's a great question i was i was
interested in that as well so we looked
into it um
i would say uh that el paso has um
an interesting history as you may know
uh because it was the
uh place where the former president uh
kind of it was a base place of where he
put in place some of his immigration
policies that we felt were so
problematic
and so it's a it's a place that has a
little bit of uh historical connection
in that regard and
it's an opportunity to draw a bit of a
contrast with what we're trying to
accomplish
can you give us any details about the
three staffers in the vice president's
office who
are leaving and what should we take from
the fact that you have several
key staffers who are leaving this early
in the administration i just don't have
any more details on the circumstances of
their departure
as you may know these are sometimes
high stress jobs tiring jobs exhausting
jobs um
and uh but i don't have anything more
specific on their decisions go ahead
following up on the server side if i can
very quickly
um obviously no details about whether he
plans to travel there has the president
now spoken to florida governor ron
desantis about the circumstances we're
working to set up a call
between the president and the governor
that should be happening this afternoon
and we'll give you all a read out of
that when it happens we'll wait for that
read out when it happens the president
yesterday spoke about voting rights and
what he would be doing he said quote
i'll be going around the country making
the case so he announced it what
specifically is he doing where is he
going and what is that going to look
like
stay tuned i don't have any specific
visits to announce for you yet but this
is going to be a fight of his presidency
he believes
that voting is a fundamental right for
the american people he's going to use
every lever at his disposal
to to advocate for that you'll hear more
from him next week as well
the doj announcement today that they
would be filing this
lawsuit against georgia given what's
going on with their election law there
did the white house play a role in that
did the president consult anybody does
he have any thought on it
uh we did not um that was a that was an
announcement they made uh on their own
uh but it certainly is consistent with
the president's
commitment to the administration and the
guidance he's given publicly and
directly
to use every lever at our disposal to
ensure we are protecting the fundamental
right to vote across the country
go ahead so on the timing of when the
president's going to get out and
advocate for voting rights i mean how
soon can we see this we're hearing
everyone from the department of justice
to activists saying that this is a
really urgent issue so how soon can we
expect this
well the president's going to speak to
all of you and to the public next week
about
his continuing commitment to voting
rights expanding access to voting rights
something that he's worked on
for decades through his public career
and i expect to have more to say then
and if you could just follow up and
maybe clarify when the president's
talking about
doing these two pieces of legislation in
tandem is he going to
wait for both of them to land on his
desk what what exactly is the timeline
here how
how does this play out well again uh he
believes
the american people elected him to uh
lead on getting results
to put out bold ideas to the public
that's exactly what he's done
and we're going to leave it to leaders
in congress to determine the sequencing
and the timeline
for those pieces moving forward but he's
going to uh use
every lever at his disposal he's going
to be involved he's going to roll up his
sleeves he's going to
work like hell to get these both of
these pieces of legislation done
what does that really look like because
he says that he's
if one doesn't come to him he's not
going to sign the other so is he going
to wait for both of them to land on his
desk before signing
the bipartisan package waiting for the
reconciliation package to come through
he fully expects hopes plans to sign
both into law
and he will leave it to leaders in
congress to determine the timeline and
the sequencing go ahead
so just follow up on that and darlene's
question the issue republicans seem to
be having is on that specific issue
i won't sign it if the other one isn't
on my desk i
think that's what has them frazzled
perhaps would be the word right now
um so digging in on that
if leadership decides to send you the
bipartisan bill but the reconciliation
bill is not done yet
the president said yesterday i won't
sign it and that is the white house
position on
well let me just take a step back here
because i think the american people are
quite focused on
how we're getting work done on their
behalf less focused on the mechanics of
the process
now it is up to republicans uh many of
them are the ones who have conveyed that
i think if i'm accurate here
to decide if they are going to vote
against a historic investment in
infrastructure that's going to rebuild
roads and railways and bridge
bridges in their communities simply
because they don't like the mechanics of
the process
that's a pretty absurd argument for them
to make good luck on the political front
on that argument
so the president's going to continue to
advocate educate convey
to everyone directly why this needs to
move forward and
he stands he plans to stand exactly by
the commitment he made
uh yesterday to them and he expects
they'll do the same
two more quick ones you guys just
released a readout with a call with
senator cena
was one of the lead negotiators in that
readout the president was reiterating
pretty much all of the things he said
when he was standing with the senators
was there a need for the president to
reassure
senator cinema or was that just a normal
decision i think it's just a reflection
of the
president's commitment to stay very
engaged yesterday was not the end i know
none of you thought that but just to be
clear
there's work ahead senator cinema isn't
it was an important leader and partner
on this effort to get this bipartisan
bill passed he also reiterated in that
call his desire and his commitment and
interest in getting a reconciliation
bill passed that has
a lot of his key priorities whether it's
extending the child tax credit
making universal pre-k a reality or
community college a reality for kids
across the country
so it's ongoing engagement he's looking
forward to signing
both bills into law good
are republicans expected to be so
enamored with the idea of sending
perhaps billions of dollars into the
hinterland
that they're going to be willing you
need five more republicans obviously
that they're going to be willing to
accept this two-track approach
and sort of look the other way when the
express train comes through
on the reconciliation idea are they you
you're sounding as though
you expect at least five more
republicans to be so
enamored with the idea of sending out
these billions of dollars to their
constituencies if they will sure well
that's exactly what they're doing this
bill would again
be a historic investment on our nation's
infrastructure the largest investment in
public transit in history
the largest in since the founding of
amtrak and as i've noted it would expand
broadband access that's not exactly a
partisan issue
that would rebuild roads and railways
and bridges in people's communities
including republicans
so yes we fully expect the american
people support this we fully expect and
hope will have the votes to get it
forward
at least five well five stood uh stood
there yesterday and announced their
support for it
and it is now the job of of the
democratic caucus and the republican
caucus to vote go back
and make the case to their uh their uh
other colleagues
exactly go ahead thank you house budget
committee chairman
john yarmuth said he doesn't think it's
realistic to fully
pay for this broader reconciliation
package that contains some of the
president's other domestic priorities
that you
just laid out senator manchin also said
he doesn't think the country can take on
that much more debt so
does the white house still believe that
both the infrastructure compromise
and this other reconciliation package
need to be fully paid for
the president's proposed uh a number of
ways to pay for these packages obviously
there was agreement already
on the pay force for the infrastructure
bipartisan deal which was agreed to by
the five democrats and the five
republicans
who stood outside with the president
just yesterday and the president also
believes that
raising the corporate rate back to where
it was the first year of the george w
bush administration making asking
individuals the top one percent of
americans to pay more
to pay for these historic investments to
pay for an extension of the child tax
credit to make sure kids have access to
universal pre-k
is something that we should do because
it's right the right policy
it will also uh it's also going to help
move our country forward
one question on afghanistan can the
president declare a true end to the war
if the u.s
is planning to keep 650 troops in the
country to provide diplomatic security
as well as several
hundred additional troops to maintain
security at the kabul airport
well again i would say the president was
clear from the beginning that we
anticipated and planned to have a
diplomatic presence on the ground and so
he's doing exactly that
on something else but on afghanistan if
we're keeping people there what's the
contingency
if in fact the taliban takes over the
country do you have a contingency
administration have a contingency for
that in what regard
for the safety of our of our men and
women serving in kabul or
i understand the safety of our people
but what about the safety of the country
we've been there for x amount of years
are we going to reinvest more people if
that's the case
will there be boots on the ground what
exactly are is this administration
looking at
if that country falls to the tower well
here's i think what's important to note
brian when the president made this
announcement he was very clear
that if we did not pull our troops with
our troops from
from afghanistan something that he has
long talked about
uh having an interest and a desire to do
the taliban would have been shooting at
u.s troops again on may first
that's a decision he had to make as
president so the withdrawal deadline
uh negotiated because of the withdrawal
deadline negotiate i should say by the
prior administration so
his fundamental belief is that after 20
years it's time to bring our troops home
we're doing that in a timely and orderly
fashion led by the department of defense
and we had to make sure we were taking
steps if we had left our troops there
they would be in harm's way that was a
step we had to take so if
the taliban takes over what would we do
well again we have i'm not going to get
ahead of or anticipate
we are we have a range of capacities
including over the horizon capacities
and
uh capabilities that we will maintain in
place the president announced that at
the beginning
of his announcement the other question
is uh is this administration
prepared for we've heard rumblings from
the former president and supporters
about
august and the inevitability of him
being reinstated is this administration
prepared
to meet the challenge if in fact they
pressed that issue
in august i mean we've already seen an
insurrection what would this
administration's actions be
if that if that is pressed in august the
president is
going is prepared to continue to govern
and lead the united states of america
and of course
uh should there be an elevation and
escalation
uh you know that is something we would
certainly monitor and track as well go
ahead jackie
reconciliation before the president made
this statement yesterday
um had there been any understanding
between the president and the gop
senators who were negotiating that these
two deals would
come in tandem had the republican
senators expressed an understanding to
the president that that would happen
well jackie i think the point i was
trying to make earlier is that it's
something the president stated
publicly many times and certainly he was
consistent with that
case made privately as were our
negotiating team that
he expected anticipated these uh these
uh
initiatives would move forward on dual
track and i would also note that
when we say budget reconciliation and
just to make it like in human speak what
we're talking about here
is a budget process that includes the
american family's plan
which is the president's idea he
proposed i don't think anyone expects
that he was going to walk away from his
own proposals
and the republicans had expressed an
understanding level of understanding
that
that
i'm not gonna let i'll let them speak
for themselves but again
the president said this as we did
multiple times publicly
um what are the red lines and the
must-haves and
is the same team working with congress
machete terrell diese about uh the next
steps in the
installation well earlier this week
space friday i think it was wednesday
we did have a number of those
individuals you mentioned as well as
susan rice was a part of the team and
there may have been one or two other
people
who went up to the hill to talk about
the budget reconciliation process
we're obviously at the early stages of
that there's lots of discuss and
negotiate
including among democrats so we'll let
that proceed
uh in the coming weeks with the doj
suing
georgia is this the beginning of more
lawsuits against similar efforts in
other states has the the white house
expressed any concern
areas as they take on voting rights uh
and
initiatives i'll let uh the the attorney
general and the department of justice
speak to that and what their plans are
they probably won't preview them i would
expect uh but i think it's just a
reflection of the fact that the
president has conveyed his priority
is using every lever at his disposal to
protect the fundamental right of people
in this country to vote
what's your timeline for these two
pieces of legislation
i don't have a new timeline to predict
for you here steve again we uh
speaker pelosi has been doing this a a
while i don't know that there's anyone
better
and we're going to work with her leader
schumer and others
to make sure we get these bills tied
into law afghanistan
is the president going to talk about a
negotiated political summit is that
still possible in afghanistan
there a political path forward is
certainly one that we continue to
support we have a negotiator as you all
know
who uh you know is a is monitoring and
closely engaged in that process and so
that is certainly ongoing
uh and will be a part of the agenda
uh on afghanistan uh in terms of siv
applicants sure the president said
yesterday this would be a topic in the
meeting today
uh can you provide clarity on what
neutral locations these applicants will
be moved towards and then also
will that withdrawal include those who
have already fled afghanistan because of
a fear of retaliation to
places like jordan or egypt yeah so let
me give you information on where we are
and it's unfortunately not going to
answer every single question some of
this we're not going to be able to
outline for security reasons but we have
identified a group of siv
applicants special immigrant visa
applicants who have served as
interpreters and translators
as well as other at-risk categories who
have assisted us
they will be relocated to a location
outside of afghanistan
before we complete our military drawdown
by september
in order to complete the visa
application process so they will do it
from another location the additional
details of that i'm just not going to be
able to speak to from here
i don't have a number to outline for you
and it's unlikely we will
uh because we are going to those are the
categories that we are prioritizing i'd
also note that
these are individuals who are already in
the siv pipeline uh and so
we under under and of course we'd under
uh undertake any relocation in full
compliance with u.s law
follow-up i know i've asked about this
good amount but from my colleagues as
well we reported yesterday
that uh the administration would lift
title 42 in a phased approach this
summer
does this summer look likely and here's
a new addition to that question
what what what will be the
administration's plan once that policy
is lifted
will it be centered on deterrence will
it be prioritizing restoring the asylum
system
well first i would say on the second
part that of course we want to restore
the asylum system and we want to make it
more operational
we want to make it more humane and
there's a lot of work we can we need to
do after the disaster of the last four
years on this front
uh in terms of the timeline of title 42
i know i keep saying this to you and i
apologize it's the same answer but
uh that is a decision that will be made
by the cdc i have nothing to
preview for you in terms of the timeline
go ahead karen what uh jen uh georgia
governor brian kemp today accused the
president and his allies of weaponizing
the justice department to undermine
election integrity what's the white
house reaction to that
i would say uh if you have such a fear
of making it easier and more accessible
for people to vote
then i would ask you what you're so
afraid of does the white house see the
justice department as its only real way
of going on offense against some of
these sweeping efforts across the
country
to implement voting restrictions that as
opposed to legislation right no we don't
it's a good question i mean it is an
area where of course the attorney
general and some of the um
as you know kristin clark venita gupta
some of the highest ranking officials in
the justice department the president
nominated
and pushed for their confirmation have
long records of advocacy
effectiveness and work on these issues
so he certainly
entrusts them with the work they're
going to continue to do on this front
we are going to continue to fight for
battle for
work toward federal legislation i know
it does not seem easy at this time
hard things we do hard things that's
what we do here but we're also going to
continue to engage and this is
as it relates to an earlier question
with local activists with local
legislators you've seen the vice
president do a bit of this
engage with and work with them we're
going to to to fight this fight on many
fronts
and certainly not the the role that the
attorney general and the justice
department may decide to take
is one but there are a number of other
ways the president the vice president
and
our administration will be continuing to
fight for voting rights
go ahead go ahead right in the middle um
today on the anniversary of shelby
versus holder oh you have
over 25 buses coming in between today
and tomorrow
on these freedom rides being led by
black voters matter has anyone
from the administration spoken with them
i know that they're going to be holding
a news conference later on today
but have you reached out to them that's
a great question i'll have to talk to
our outreach team and
some other senior members of the team to
see if they have been engaged directly
with them i don't know
when it comes to the president i'm
trying to
lower crime rate in the midst of this
spike there have been many reports
showing that putting money adding more
money to
police departments does not necessarily
correlate with lowering crime
why did the president decide to do that
and or
instead of attaching it within the order
to having the police departments
do have some type of system where they
have to do something in order
to receive that type of money well first
i would say that the president
and we saw some positive steps forward
just yesterday on police reform in the
negotiations
uh that's certainly a positive step the
president believes we need to do both
and many most people in most communities
across the country where there's rising
crime
agree and what the president announced
just a couple of days ago
was uh primarily a plan to to reduce gun
violence which he feels is a
big driver of violence across the
country but i would say community
policing
and is something that we've seen as
effective rebuilding trust in
communities ensuring that
uh that law enforcement are working on
behalf of communities
that's what he was proposing uh funding
to go towards that is different than
a step as it relates to the criminal
justice system
back about um creating a police
oversight commission
well i think a number of activists have
conveyed that that is not their pri
their preference for the path forward
they want to see this legislation
move forward we've seen some progress on
that farm so that's where we're going to
put bad the basket we're going to put
our eggs go in the middle yeah now that
uh vice president harris is visiting the
border
when will president biden visit i don't
have anything to predict for you or
preview for you as the president has
said the vice president said back in
march she'd be open to visiting the
border and if it's
constructive and moves the ball forward
for the president to visit it
i'm sure he may but we come with a bunch
of people as you all know
on voting rights um i just i just want
to be clear are you
saying that the white house had no
contact with the justice department
about this decision
uh to move forward in georgia um
is is the justice department completely
independent
no i'm not it's a it's a priority to the
president but and
yes of course we are well allowed to
know but it is
uh i was not meaning to convey that but
it is a decision made
by the justice department to move
forward but clearly a priority of the
president to
take action wherever we can in
government to make it more accessible to
vote for people across the country go
ahead
let me go to her personally thanks jen
um when you talk about engaging
at the state level voting rights yeah
what does that look like
aside from travel how will the
administration be scrutinizing
new laws going into place well you saw
the department of justice taking action
today that's an example
but you've also seen the vice president
meet with legislators
and work and talk with them about the
path forward and how we can work
together
to fight back against uh
efforts to suppress the vote across the
country so those are two examples but
also engaging with activists i will say
there are a lot of people in this
building
who know a lot about how to engage
educate empower
people to know what their rights are we
want to work with states and local
authorities to do exactly that but the
president will be talking about this
more next week
does the administration believe that's
making a difference in
republican-controlled state legislatures
we'll have to see uh go ahead the
president of angola presidential lorenzo
was at the united nations
this week and his main goal there for
his main focus
was to advocate to end the armed
embargo that is going on on the central
in the central african republic
and president lorenzo is now the acting
president
of the international conference on the
great lake region
so he know the area he has done a lot of
work to bring peace and security in this
region that's why he advocated strongly
to end the embargo but the united states
wants to continue the embargo do you
know what is the main reason or what
what is the interest of the united
states to keep
the embargo on the central african
republic i'd really point you to our u.n
ambassador linda thomas greenfield or
the state department for that question
go ahead i think we have to move on go
ahead is there any
situation in which the president would
sign the bipartisan
infrastructure deal without an
accompanying
reconciliation bill the president fully
expects and plans to sign both pieces of
uh of legislation into law okay
um the end of the supreme court term is
next week
uh does the president or the white house
expect any retirements
and what would the message from the
president be to a justice who might be
thinking about
uh hanging up the robe it's a decision
for them to make as an individual and he
would support whatever decision they
make go ahead um
president biden met with financial
regulators earlier this week
i'm wondering if there is any discussion
about buy now pay later companies so
like karna
firm after pay these are becoming very
popular in the us and retail
transactions and europe recently made
moves a few months back to regulate them
it's very thing you can tell me about
that you know we provided a readout of
the meeting and what the focus of the
meeting is what was which was to provide
an update in the
state of the uh financial markets uh to
talk about
uh how how they can work to make credit
more accessible
i just don't have anything more to read
out for you you could certainly you
could certainly
reach out to any of the regulars if they
want to speak about anything they raised
but i don't have more of a readout from
here no discussion
from the white house i would point you
to the regulars i don't have any more to
read out from here go ahead jen
the president is meeting shortly with
president ghani and chairman of
abdullah they met yesterday with the
senate's
minority leader and after that meeting
he called for a reversal of course
by this administration to avoid a
taliban takeover afghanistan
contending that'll give rise to renewed
terrorism threats to the u.s homeland
what is your response to
senator mcconnell on that i would first
say it's important to take a step back
uh and remember what we inherited uh won
the lowest number of u.s and partner
forces in afghanistan
since the early days of the war to an
agreement between the united states and
the taliban to draw down all u.s
troops by may first just three months
after inauguration day a very short
timeline
and three a military stalemate between
the taliban and afghan forces
that's the hand we were dealt the
president made a decision which is
consistent with his view
that this was not a winnable war to
bring the u.s
troops home some after 20 years of
fighting this war
and a big part of that decision was also
around the fact that if we left our
troops there
our troops would be at risk because the
taliban would be shooting them
by may 1st that's the basis of it uh are
there challenges to it
of course will we continue to be engaged
as is today is evidence of
with the government about how we can
continue to provide humanitarian
security support
yes we will will we have a presence on
the ground yes we will
but that was a decision the president
made uh with all of those factors
involved go ahead
thank you good to see you again oh hello
boyle how are you
thank you again good to see you quick
two questions please one
on the u.s india relations of course
prime minister modi have
spoken with president quite a number of
times
and have they at the level of moving
forward u.s india relations
now between the two of them and as far
as the
vaccine is concerned and where do we
stand well i would say goyle that
um the india is an incredibly important
partner
uh to the united states in the region
and globally and we work with india on a
range of issues as you well know
economic strategic security and the
united states
certainly took a range of steps as india
was at the early stages of dealing with
a rise in the pandemic
to help provide a range of assistance
and we will continue to do that moving
forward
go ahead i'm sorry we got it we've got
we're going to run out of time so i just
want to get to as many people as
possible go ahead
sure texas governor greg abbott released
a statement saying that he would have
preferred the vice president went to the
del rio
sector or the rio grande area any
response to that and secondly
was there any communication between the
vice president's office so you can tell
us about
with the governor's office about a
potential meeting
a meeting with the governor between the
vice president the doctor
uh i am happy to check with them and see
if there was or if that was ever a part
of uh
of the plans and i'll i'll get back to
that his criticism about where she went
today well i would say the purpose of
the vice president's visit as we've
outlined was to
she's long said she would be open to
visiting the border
she's doing that with secretary mayorkas
who oversees uh
the border and has has helped lead a
range of progress there
that we've seen over the last couple of
months and there certainly is a
connection between the important work
the vice president's doing in the
northern triangle
where we've also seen a reduction in
migration of unaccompanied children
since march and since april uh so that's
the purpose of their visit
in terms of direct consultation with the
governor i'm happy to check and see if
there's more
i can read out for you go ahead in the
middle in the back
yeah go ahead go ahead and then i'll go
to you right now but
on the governor's uh meeting with
western governors next week
can you tell us anything about which
governor's invited what we're going to
expect
and then specifically the president
mentioned he was surprised at just how
little federal
wildland firefighters paid what would
the administration do
uh well one we could pass a federal
minimum wage
which would represent a higher wage than
it seems the firefighters are getting
uh but certainly he uh will continue to
advocate for
uh additional support and assistance for
the men and women serving
as firefighters in the country let me
give you a sense of the governor's
coming so
the meeting first will focus on how the
federal government can
improve wildfire preparedness and
response efforts protect public safety
and deliver assistance to
our people in times of urgent need as a
former local elected official himself
maybe he will always feel that way in
his heart i think
um he feels it's really important to
engage directly
sit with people uh as you can either
remotely or in person
to really discuss what the holdups are
what the challenges are how can we help
be better partners from the federal
government and so this is an example of
that
governor kate brown governor of oregon
governor of california gavin newsom
governor of new mexico michelle lujan
grisham
governor of wyoming mark gordon governor
of colorado jared polis
governor of utah spencer cox and
governor of nevada steve siselek will be
the governors who will be in attendance
that governor little and governor jim
forte are not invited
that's the list of attendees i have i
can certainly check if there's more on
who or was or wasn't invited oh go ahead
i said i would go to you right next yeah
and we'll we'll make sure we get to a
promise but remember more specifics
about what the president and the white
house will do
over the next week to continue to boost
support for this infrastructure bill
can can we expect him to be on the phone
with republicans that
have expressed concerns about his
comments yesterday or
uh you can expect as is evidenced by the
fact that he called senator he had a
conversation with senator
cena sir semina cinema yeah it's a
friday
it's a hard one uh senator cinema this
morning uh that he will of course be on
the phone uh and he will be engaging
directly with members of both parties
about
uh moving uh his priorities forward uh
you know sometimes that's scheduled or
planned a day in advance or the day
before
so i don't have more specifics for you
but as they happen we'll read them out
for you
yeah has he called any of the republican
senators today
obviously you were mentioning earlier
that he's talked about this publicly
what his stance was
there are republican senators that are
surprised by
yesterday and are upset as has been
reported
so has he talked to them today what is
he doing to sort of
keep this deal uh intact well first i
think what he's doing anita is
continuing to convey and provide details
to the public
who care deeply about whether he's
delivering for them less about the
mechanics of the process
about why this should be a package
that's supported broadly by democrats
and republicans
across congress so that's what i did
certainly at the beginning and that's
the case
he's going to continue to make call any
of those senators today though i don't
have any additional calls to read out
uh i think let's see go ahead go ahead
thanks so much jen um
versus following up on an earlier
question sure with the special immigrant
visa population from afghanistan um does
the
united states plan to protect those
translators
and people who worked for americans who
have already fled
afghanistan and are in different
countries currently
well there are individuals who are
already in the siv pipeline i suppose
some of them might not be i can
certainly
might not be still there i can certainly
check and see if they're if they've
already departed afghanistan how that
would apply
another question about the manatee
population in florida
um they are not that was not on my bingo
card today but i'm happy to answer it
okay
well the wall street journal had a good
article about them this week they are
dying at a record pace um 800 of them
died in the last year and i wanted to
see if the administration believes
that these animals um should be relisted
as
endangered and also whether anything
inviting this infrastructure deal that
he struck yesterday would
continue on um to help with uh
part of the problem is that the um the
florida waters are not clean
and it's hurting their habitat yeah
i will say in all seriousness i mean
certainly it's an important question an
important issue um i don't want the
the pro-manatee people to not think i
feel that um
but i will say that um yes there are
components of his
of his package i mean a part of this
package a big part of this package is
is a down payment on uh climate
resilience
uh on uh ensuring that uh we are
cleaning up
some of the polluted areas in our
country something that is impacting
a lot of communities proportionately
more than others um
so that is i would have to check and
sort of what that means for the florida
coast i think you said specifically
there in terms of
uh relisting them it's a great question
i just have to talk to the
folks who would be more specific about
that go ahead thank you
african journalists many protesters
outside the white house they are waiting
and they have a right
expectation from today's two presidents
meeting do you have any message for them
because
as soon as i leave here i'll go to see
them and get their opinion
well i would say that um the the meeting
today
is an opportunity to convey uh from the
president that we
have an ongoing commitment we are
committed to supporting
the afghan people and the afghan
national defense and security forces
even as we continue to undertake a
security transition
uh the president is also going to
emphasize during this meeting
the need for unity cohesion and for the
afghan government to focus on the key
challenges
of afghanistan faces and so as you noted
we'll welcome both
president ghani and chairman abdullah
and one of the most important
messages he will stress is that they
need to have a united front as
afghanistan continues to address
security and other challenges and
finally he will emphasize our continuing
diplomatic support for the peace process
and for all afghan parties to engage in
good faith
and that process so the bottom line that
you can convey is that
uh he's going to discuss our enduring
united states support including through
security assistance the afghan national
defense
and security forces development
humanitarian assistance
to support the afghan people and
diplomatic engagement and support of
peace
oh thank you guys i'm sorry you've got
to you've got to gather oh i'm sorry
chris
chris chris and then i i want to go to
omni because it's her first time too so
okay
all right pride um i know we're going to
start on time let's go smoosh my
multiple inquiries a day on the lgbt
developments into one
and that is uh take your time it's okay
people can leave if they need to gather
no one is rushing you out of here
uh the initiatives today how do they
place
and uh the president's both domestic and
foreign policy agenda
and don't they fall short of the
president signing the equality act into
law
well first on the well let me start with
the first one because i think that's an
important question because what we do
here and the values that we
advocate for in the united states do
send an important message around the
world and sometimes we forget that so
during his remarks today the president
will outline of course the historic step
his
his administration has taken but he will
also renew his calls
on the senate to swiftly pass the
equality act and provide overdue
explicit civil rights protections to
lgbtq people
and families across the country he will
also speak directly to the proliferation
of state-level anti-lgbtq
bill plus bills denouncing them as
un-american and legislation disguised as
bullying
and he will commend the community for
their courage and bravery pushing
progress forward
finally he will announce his appointment
of jessica stern as the u.s
envoy to advance the human rights of
lgbtq persons at the department of state
a role just to make the connection here
uh that will be critical to advancing
his agenda
uh overseas and around the world as well
uh i don't have anything to preview in
terms of travel beyond next week
maybe we don't work too far ahead and
planning around these parts um but
uh certainly the fact that he's signing
this legislation today sends a clear
message about
um you know his commitment to the lgbtq
plus community
and to commemorating what was a tragedy
in our nation's history i'm okay last
one and then everybody can gather
amazon the newshour has been in touch
with alabama spokesman so gail shaheen
ran by him the reports of hundreds of
additional u.s forces staying beyond the
withdrawal
this is his response he says it's a
violation of the commitment and the
agreement made by the u.s
it jeopardizes the peace process and
could pave the way for continued
prolonged
war so what's the white house response
to that uh i
i would say first that we have been very
clear and the president was when he made
his announcement about his plans to
withdrawal troops that we plan to have a
diplomatic presence on the ground
including including a security presence
to protect
our diplomatic presence on the ground
and that's something that
has been a part of the discussion from
the beginning um
and beyond that i certainly would have
to talk to our national security team if
there's more
one more quick one the family of mark
freericks who a u.s navy veteran who is
still held hostage in afghanistan
he's worried that as u.s troops continue
to leave you've lost all leverage in any
efforts to free him so what's the
president's message
to his family the president's message is
that he will continue to fight every day
of his presidency to bring americans
home
who are detained overseas uh in whether
it's in afghanistan or any other country
around the world again we will have a
diplomatic presence on the ground we
will continue to work closely with the
government with
security support humanitarian support
and there needs to be
continued a continued political process
ongoing negotiations that will be part
of the president's message today when he
meets with the leaders
thanks everyone so much happy friday
you